oui alors c'est vrai que ce qui est très
particulier dans ces débats dans ces
débats télévisés c'est qu'on peut
apprécier le show c'est à dire ceux qui
s'affairent les pics lors du premier
débat jean luc mélenchon avait été
impérial
celui qui était pas mauvais hier c'était
d'une certaine manière dupont aignan
donc on voit bien aussi qu'il ya du
métier au sens de l'expérience quand
vous avez 35 ans de congrès de débats
parlementaires à l'assemblée ou au sénat
vous avez plus plus de tchatche plus de
savoir-faire
mais sur le fond sur les solutions moi
ce que j'apprécie beaucoup dans le la
candidature de benoît hamon c'est sa
façon de défendre ses propositions c'est
justement de ne pas en faire trop
ne pas se mettre en scène et puis
surtout d'apporter de vraies réponses
continuera le de la moralisation de la
vie politique
quand il parle des questions d'emploi il
dit des choses très précises